all right uh let's get into the draft
then general managers that you would
like to be over the course of the next
two weeks specifically nine days from
now when the new league year begins
trivia question for you christopher
which west virginia alumnus has the most
quarterback wins as a starter in the
national football league
yeah this is a good one here um
[Music]
because i
i i honestly i want to just
i can't think of anybody else who really
had
like winning game i'm gonna go with jeff
hosteller i'm gonna say that
what is that right also once had shaving
cream in his shoes awesome i had that
yeah i just that that that i i just it's
not a storied you know college as far as
quarterbacks in the nfl i couldn't think
of anybody else that really had that
type of uh mark bulger mark bulger had
been close right gotten some yes yeah i
would think he was probably a year or
two away
um all right well
uh listen i i'm gonna take like low
hanging fruit to start here
i mean one i'm going with jacksonville
just off the bat right here
why i mean gm's we'd like to be
oh wait i get my pick of whoever i want
as the number one quarterback in the
draft coming up and i have wait oh let
me check 85 million dollars of cash two
weeks
next two weeks so the draft thing down
although you still know you've got this
exactly that's what i mean so now you
don't have to worry about that you can
just be you could sell hey
you know we got this special quarterback
we love and he's coming to town and all
that and we can pay you a little bit
more money than everybody else on the
market you know because we have more so
there's something to be excited about
that you could sell the players and of
course you could add a little icing on
the cake too because you got so much
money i mean to me that's that's i'm
really intrigued to see how jacksonville
plays this free agency how trent balke
and urban meyer kind of want to
spread the wealth of their football team
and what they want to do within that
vision of urban meyer too
jaguars have been around for 26 years
they've never had the number one overall
pick in the draft and 84 million in cap
space that was my first pick as well
next pick team with 77 million in
projected caps base and the number two
overall pick in the draft and you know
some assets like a sam darwin who could
be traded to another team to enhance
your standing in the draft and oh
they're already
holding the knowledge even though we're
just talking about the next two weeks
that they've got a second first round
pick from jamal adams so they can really
go out and do some shopping they can do
some things to reshape the team continue
to build from the inside out not the
outside in not don't don't go sign a
le'veon bell type of a guy this year get
linemen offensive and defensive
alignment and also also since it's a
two-week window
i would resist the urge as long as
possible to go out and spend big money
for the sake of spending big money
because someone always does that and
they end up regretting it and the
bargains come after you get through the
first few days of free agency it's just
hard to get teams
every year there's always going to be a
handful of teams that say the hell with
that we're going to go spend i i would
resist being one of those teams if i was
the jets well
well why what what do you what do you
want to why do you want to resist it
what's what's that because you overspend
you overpay if you go out first day of
free agency and buy up some player like
chris godwin you're going to pay him too
much that's how you get the deal done on
the first day you get a better value if
you wait several days for the market to
cool down because i think this year
there's going to be more guys available
than ever before once the market cools
off yeah i hear you so yeah that makes
sense i mean you know you might have
that one or two guys that you look at
you go okay we're willing to pay for
for more for them but we're going to sit
back in the way those guys never work
out when do those guys ever work out
they just did that with tremaine johnson
a few years ago and it didn't work out
how many of those guys actually work out
those guys who hold up the jersey the
first day of free agency how many of
those guys become integral parts of a
team
day one of free agency multi-year deal
record setting for his position how many
of those guys become key parts of a
championship contender not many yeah i
know you're right probably not i got i'd
have to think about it a little off the
top of my head i was going to say
deforest buckner last year but he ended
up getting traded that wasn't a free
agent or anything like that so i i hear
you that i mean it's it's a solid point
there's no doubt about that um i think
the next one
i'm gonna look at
there's so many good ones to pick here i
mean there really is there's some
interesting ones i'm gonna go i'll go
just the miami dolphins
i'll look at them to where they just got
a lot to play with here now they're not
like yeah a ton of money like the
patriots and some of the other teams but
they're still sitting in a really good
position with 36 million dollar left in
the salary cap and with all the draft
picks they have too
hey they they they can look at their
football team
look at their roster and go hey we're in
a pretty good spot we don't have like
anything that's just an absolute
desperate need so they're going to be
able to be picky and choosy within free
agency and if there's a player out there
that they is because like you said teams
are going to be looking to trim the fat
and do those things they got the assets
and the draft picks with what two first
two seconds right to play with and
figure out uh if they want to get rid of
one of those to make a play or do that
so it'd be fun to be a gm for the miami
dolphins right now especially and of
course you're in the desean watson
conversation as soon as houston starts
to answer a call there
23 million in projected cap space which
which is it's better than the
alternative but it's not some of the big
numbers that we've seen and that's why
i'd go new england patriots which i
guess makes me bill belichick since he's
really the guy with the juice there so i
would have eight super bowl rings so i
would like to have those for a couple of
weeks so i could put him on and flash
him like he did before super bowl 54 but
66 million in cab space blank slate at
quarterback a lot of holes to fill i
mean the challenge is there but you have
the opportunity to do it and they
planned for this
they and i would say that they're one of
the teams that lobbied very aggressively
against bumping the salary cap up to
help the teams that didn't plan because
they planned they knew which way the
ball was moving as a result of the
pandemic and they stockpiled caps base
and you know the argument can be made
that they they deliberately
i wouldn't say threw in the towel last
year but they knew that last year was
going to be tough to compete so they
opted to carry cap space into this year
and and have the advantage that comes
from being a great organization with a
great coaching staff that can go out and
buy up a bunch of cheaper players going
into
2021 and uh that's what they have the
opportunity to do with 66 million
dollars in cap space i know i'm
interested to see how they attack this
obviously we know they got holes they
need to fill they got some guys coming
back from you know the coven 19 list and
all that that's great but the team needs
to be improved and where i look at it
with new england where i'm always
interested is you know it's always about
value with them whether it's the draft
or a free agency i mean typically
belichick seems to be a guy that trades
down on the draft because
oh players we have doesn't mix the value
or whatever so we're going to trade down
and
get a bargain somewhere else free agency
they've been the same way you know that
it's rare that they make a
first week splash you know they're kind
of one of those teams that you kind of
talk about mike where they kind of let
all the big guys go
and then they try to find oh now
let me look at the second cut of free
agency and i think there's some guys in
here that should have been maybe on the
first cut but they they are going to get
paid like the second cut and they get
those type of values and i'll i'm going
to be interested to see how they attack
that
all right tight on time we got two
rounds down one to go chris who's your
third round pick for the gm you want to
be for the next two weeks hey i look at
washington football team and i like that
but they got to fix the quarterback
situation so i don't know if that's the
gm i want to be the one that really
jumps out to me the colts all right with
they got their quarterback they got a
team that's in the super bowl window
and now chris ballard who i look at is
one of the best gm's in football
you know
41 million in cap space
you know projected or closer to 50
million when you take the top 51 on the
roster there then i know we don't know
the exact number but i just look at that
as going wow they got they don't need a
lot they got depth they got everything
you need on that football team now it's
just about maybe getting a star or two
that are difference makers
and look i also would like to have a
relaxing couple of weeks if possible if
i'm bucks gm jason light i'm just trying
to keep my guys i'm not going out
shopping oh and i have a lombardi trophy
oh
from one boat to another that i can just
sit outside
suckers work for the next two weeks i'm
gonna sit here and enjoy my new trophy
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports